bonjour gilbert casasus merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
énième round de pourparlers des
négociations sans fin le bout du tunnel
c'est pour bientôt
la 'deadline' on le rappelle c'est dans
moins de 50 jours et ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à des avancées cette semaine
ou encore une fois au statu quo je pense
que on peut s'attendre à quelques
petites avancées
plus le temps avance plus la situation
de bord une somme que fragilise on a vu
la semaine dernière on ya quelques jours
la démission de comics de meunier
communiquer quand même la personne qui a
acquis le plus proche cher auprès de
boris johnson pour impulser le bric site
et puis malgré tout la victoire
certainement acquis face à trump n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle non plus pour
fonctionne donc frost a bel et bien
raison
stratégiquement d'appuyer là où ça fait
mal et de réaffirmer les positions
britanniques mais c'est très bien qu'il
ne sera pas en mesure de faire en sorte
que les britanniques surtout vainqueur
de ce bras de fer
justement vous venez de parler de la
démission de dominique que wings le
proches conseillers de boris johnson
il ya également eu le départ du
directeur de communication du premier
ministre deux hommes qui ont contribué
au break site est ce que ça pourrait
être un signe en faveur de bruxelles
malgré comme vous l'avez dit la dernière
sortie de david frost
je pense que ça démontre avant tout des
désaccords internes à londres ça c'est
pour le plus important est de johnson
qui avait largement gagné environ un an
les élections n'est plus le johnson
d'aujourd'hui et en politique il habite
mais souvenons nous dit
quelques temps qu'il ya trois quatre ans
ou du bric site
on disait ça va faire tache d'huile il y
avait des responsables politiques
français par exemple qui parut du fric
site qui est ce qu'ils parlent
aujourd'hui en france du fric si plus
personne à cause justement du bric site
c'est facile de dire on sort mais ce qui
est pas facile c'est de savoir comment
sort et à quel prix
et c'est ça le problème numéro un de la
grande bretagne de grande bretagne a
joué avec un vent favorable sauf que un
piquet maritime nous à savoir le vent
tourner quand le vent tourne et bien on
le prend en pleine figure
et c'est exactement ce qui est plus de
moi en train de se passer
où l'on lui à londres boris johnson qu'à
contacter placé à l'isolément une
nouvelle fois on sait qu'ils avaient été
infectés par le corona virus au
printemps dernier quelles conséquences
pour les négociations de cette semaine
avec cette nouvelle mise en quarantaine
pour pour boris johnson je ne gèreraient
pas surfaite n'est pas rée atteint du
comité je l'espère qu'il ne le soit pas
c'est quelqu'un qui est assez souffert
d'être un peu pas ça faut qu'on profonde
ne va pas ici faire un tribunal si vous
voulez ça plutôt une valeur de symbole
de cette fragilité britannique qui est
aujourd'hui s'exprime et cette fragilité
britannique n'est pas bonne elle n'est
surtout pas bonnes pour les britanniques
eux mêmes c'est ça qui est le point
essentiel ce qu'ils sont en train de
piller un peu le prix de cette politique
à l'emporte-pièce sont les britanniques
mais dans un autre sens majoritairement
ils ont voulu donc lorsqu'on évoque dans
un référendum mais simplement il faut
savoir aussi que c'est appliqué et que
ne font pas les promesses du référendum
qui est peuvent toujours être traduite
dans les fêtes comme on l'espérait cette
semaine je suppose qu'il va de nouveau y
avoir des menaces par rapport à
no deal encore une fois d'une partie ou
de l'autre s'il devait ne pas y avoir
d'accord au 31 décembre
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
concrètement une crise de part et
d'autre de chaque côté de la manche
alors la crise si on en arrive à un new
deal est clair et net
par ailleurs ce sont surtout les
britanniques qui en paierait le prix
c'est pas du tout eux qui auront intérêt
alors ils jouent beaucoup actuellement
on peut le comprendre
sur la pêche là ils ont certes un
certain nombre d'arguments
manque de chance pour eux le pays le
plus concerné ou l'inde et pays le plus
concerné par la pêche et la france mais
la france elle est là un sacré argument
serait la frontière avec la
grande-bretagne le tunnel sous la manche
imaginez vous que macro parce que ce
serait des douaniers français se
seraient pas les douaniers polonais
slovaques ou suédois qui dit voilà
maintenant vous allez contrôler de façon
très poussée
tous les camions britannique qui arrive
sur le sol européen
vous allez fouiller tous les camions
européens qui vont en grand-bretagne
donc si d'un côté dans les zones sonne à
l'argument de la pêche
de l'autre côté macro l'union européenne
ont l'argument des camions et des
contrôles douaniers
merci j'espère qu'à sa sucette avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes un spécialiste du président
professeur ordinaire en études
européennes auprès de la faculté de
lettres de l'université de fribourg en
suisse